I figured out the best way to welcome
pimento to the nine-nine stay out of his
way maybe buy him a drink not do
anything weird I'm making him a goat
stew huh all right yeah now this
turkmenistan a dish is traditionally
made from an animal that's been so
overfed it can no longer stand that's
the dream everything is authentic I even
ordered the pressure cooker from
Turkmenistan so you're on a terrorist
watch list now
oh yeah Homeland Security's been in my
house yep now this just needs to cook
for another 11 hours 32 minutes and six
I'm not going to make an accident
Terry's gonna die saving the president
oh geez never gonna die there's no way
we can clean this up by ourselves we're
gonna need help what are you saying you
know what she's saying man Oh No
hey Marge so we're supposed to come
running to clean up your mess every time
you snap your fat little fingers oh no
no I actually can't snap my fingers are
always too wet and I just thought since
it's your job oh I see you cops think
you're too good to clean up after
yourselves no I can do myself
I'll just union work how dare you try to
steal our jobs so where do we go from
here
Oh you know the old saying the only way
to unclog a toilet is to let it sit
you're a janitor you should know that's
not true
boys take out the trash oh great so you
will do it
Oh on the trash I get okay that makes
more sense with your tone okay love you
Marge
you